wow this milkshake is incredible
right this is how i spend most of my
time sitting in beautiful places
drinking my milkshake slowly peeing into
my pants
which instantly evaporates and leaves no
trace
sounds fun but didn't you want to tell
us how we're all screwed
ah damn it this is the exact
problem on paper this is
paradise all your desires and needs are
met but it's infinite
and when perfection goes on forever you
become this
glassy-eyed mush person but
no because no
because patty no yes i'm telling you
i used to be cool man i studied so much
things art and music
and the um the one with the number
piles where i'd be like two and you'd be
like
six math yes and then i came
here where time stretched out forever
and every second of my existence was
amazing but my brain became this big
dumb blob so we finally make it into the
good
place and now we're just gonna become
zombies why haven't you told anyone
about this
about what dude damn it
we have to find the others right now
look there's math on my shirt
come on is it an s or a map
have you seen eleanor and chidi there's
something very wrong with this party and
it's not just that the caviar is being
served on top of
jello shots we are the first new people
here in 500 years
and no one seems to care i know even the
good janets are kind of weird
they're like hi there when i do it it's
cool but when they do it it's
lame hey guys having fun great so
a little update um the good place is a
disaster
everyone here is a happiness zombie and
no one is doing anything about it
because by the time they realize it's
happening everyone is too far gone to
care
oh dear oh hello i'm tahani hi
i'm milkshake do you want a milkshake
okay we need to tell someone before
we're too zonked out to remember why
we're here we need to find the committee
the committee is me
i am committee it me what they tricked
me
and put me in charge of the good place
and then literally ran away
and then what happened the sorting hat
put you in hufflepuff roasted
come on i know we have problems you
can't expect me to ignore this hang on
we're in paradise surely some people
here are enjoying themselves hey guys
i'm back go carty but monkeys got boring
really fast
you